證據話說得太好了
任何一個還在為溫暴而憤鬥的人
一定缺乏想像力
誰說呢奧斯卡班兒子
昨天有消白國留言說胡澤英
介紹幾個書啊
我是好
但是這次就要說
和去年前面不一樣
不是讓你讀幾年
不是讓你讀一整年
讓你短短讀幾個月的
就是從現在開始到過年這段時間讀
改變現在的思維的
思維太重要了
我發現我們很多人
有完全局限在自己的行業
自己的領域
自己的低運
就被關於那個龍住領
大腦啊
嚴重受限
舉個例子
我原淡的前一天
我出了一個計劃
我說什麼呢
我說每天抽出
一到兩小時就做最重要的事
然後第二個什麼呢
就是每天所以八個小時
結果留言最多的事
不可能
對吧工作都忙死了都累死了
怎拿我時間去休息
你以後發工資
當我看到
這樣多留言的時候
我就知道
就你的思維是嚴重受限了
就這些人他經常是把什麼呢
他在就計劃的時候
是把一天的工作時間跑出去
一天工作八小時
用工的十小時
用工的十二小時
然後再去算
我或者這時間
我多少用的
但思考一下
難道你每天
每週工作五天
然後最後就準備了休息兩天
結果那兩天那個跟狗一樣
然後天
第二週接著
拉姆拉五天
然後再休息兩天
所以我推薦的第一本書
我沒想到我還有
手臉還有這個
這本書
沒有問題
每週工作四小時
我覺得大家可以看一下
就是不是說
你每天
必須工作十小時
才能中到雙後飛
對吧
你做了目的不就為了中後飛嗎
當然有人有更為大的目的
目前了
我們說基礎的
就是不再掌聲我對嗎
真的需要每一天工作十天嗎
這本書的話
告訴你也方法
每週工作四小時
當然你是長事的話
你不一定完全說
每週四小時
可能是每週八小時
可能每週十二小時
可能每週二十小時
但是絕對用不了
每週五十小時就這麼說話費
我就看一看吧
對你是有幫助的
這是第一本書
第二本書
完全被書名毀了
這本書的名叫什麼呢
叫百萬負問快車道
你看那名答一看
什麼就是
這是
這是同學嗎
對吧
但是這本書
其實是非常好的一本書
特別的時候
就是你開拓事業
那什麼什麼漫車道呢
有快車段要漫車道
漫車道就準備
你上學
然後是好學習
公眾高中
然後大學
然後工作
早工作一直公開去
他說這個叫漫車道
但是還有一個很快車道
就是你很快的
發現生活中的一些需求
或者市場的一些機會
然後快做短短幾年
你就可以活得一些收益
就像這個大玩兒在書裡說的
有些行業啊
雖然只有短短幾年的時間
但是就這幾年
你就抓住了
那你就可以財富自由了
我不是說大家一定要做這樣的事情
但是我建議來好好看一看
它開過行的思考原來人生
還可以這麼過
改變你思議的
我就得非常好開過思路的
第三本書
我以前看了看的時候
我就特別好
最近又反而開開
誰不然分
我以前航空的一個
我以前真的那個
對吧
但真的的話呢
它有點數
叫至所有瘋狂的假好
我特別喜歡看著這說
就經常有一些
就是它平時日常的生活中
看到的
就把它總結化成生意了
比如說有一個小故事
就它去不多立刻
結果會多立刻那個飛機
就是
就取消了
結果航案路
航案路裡全是人
全是巡的地方
好了
這流了嗎
然後就給那個
包機公司打電話
好有一個人
還找到一個便宜的
三、兩千塊
兩千美金
飛到不得了一個
它一算作為
一除
每個人三十幾萬錢
它就找個小黑板
叫個小黑板
那個拍子
維遇真航空
每一個作為三十幾萬錢
然後做完了
飛到那邊以後的話
就人下了飛機
就可能說
你這個飛機還是不錯的
在提升一些服務
你的航空公司
就可以開業了
所以大家可以看
它整個做生的那個過程
真的就是
有些時候就是一些
一些
其實生活中都不快樂
但它把它組合成了一種生意
組合成了一種機會
我建議大家
好看一看
還那句話
我那句話怎麼說來的
來我把句話
這句話找一找
任何一個還在為
文寶而憤怒的人
一定是缺乏現行李的
而事實上你的航力
一家打開
你的世界又開火了
所以推薦三本書
也不是說你看一年
看幾天
就是從現在
到過年段時間
開多一些事業的